a beautiful weekend on tap ted yeah
great weekend for that too right
but prepare for delays because
everyone's going to be trying to put
their boat in the water
this is the weekend for that and we also
have some wind to deal with and we get a
little bit of wind at the lake
you get choppy water and that makes it a
little hazardous for boating we're going
to show you that in just a bit
first though live look outside looking
down to 95 beautiful day outside it is
hotter
98 degrees our high so far
and that's above average for sure 93 is
where we should be the record for this
date 109 degrees
let's get to some neighborhoods shall we
the far west side summerlin at 91.
99 currently for centennial hills 94 for
the lakes
also 99 downtown in north las vegas
already at the century mark
for sunrise manor green valley 98 also
still 100 for you in southern highlands
seven hills 96
and 98 henderson rhodes ranch mountain's
edge at 94. same goes for
boulder city 97 at the century mark also
for
laughlin 105 for you out in your county
out in death valley there's the showers
off in the four corners region clear
here though
and a few showers up there near wells in
elko but otherwise we're remaining dry
what we will see is a low that will sag
down
and south of us and what that will do is
increase clouds for us tomorrow so your
saturday won't just be clear and sunny
we're going to add some clouds to mix in
with some sunshine unfortunately those
clouds are not going to bring us any
rain
and then sunday we're looking at mostly
sunny skies and same goes for monday too
now winds tomorrow
really aren't going to be too bad for
the valley at least most neighborhoods
again less than 10 miles per hour
but the lake however will have some
gusty winds at times for
tomorrow so tonight 72 degrees mostly
clear and nice a very comfortable and
pleasant evening
increased clouds for tomorrow 96 are
high this time around
and that is still above average some
light breezes expected if you're going
to the lake tomorrow
99 it's going to be hot we'll be gusty
too so careful uh
boating make sure you're working wearing
the life vest for sure the certified
life vests
if you're headed up to the mountain 72
degrees a very nice day for tomorrow
partly sunny and comfortable
red rock if you're going hiking will be
90 degrees for you here's your eight day
forecast now temperatures getting close
to 100 will reach it officially
area wide maybe as early as monday
certainly tuesday
heading into next week too look at that
back 104 to 103 degrees the heat
is here that is your most accurate
forecast we sent brian loftus down to
toshiba plaza to rally the crowd for
tonight's game seven
brian how is it down there buddy
it's exactly what you'd expect ted